le 20 minutes médias on revient sur un
dessin animé qui cartonne auprès des
enfants hépatiques
et si papa pique se retrouve au coeur de
l'actualité c'est pour cette séquence
diffusée cette semaine je suis peiné
lors scolaire je vis avec ma maman et
mon autre maman dans le dessin animé on
découvre donc pour la première fois un
couple homoparental nouveautés demande
est saluée par la communauté lgbt mais
critiqué par certains et papiers il
vient d'inclure un couple gay je savais
que ce jour allait arriver et ça
m'énerve vraiment ce match aller mais
vous comprenez vous la polémique
comprenez vous la polémique autour de ce
dessin animé alors je reprécise
talayssat n'aimait vraiment qu'ils
arrêtent aux tout-petits voilà donc est
ce que les petits de moins de 3 ans une
conscience autour de la famille
recomposée tu sais c'est la question
vous ne comprenez pas la polémique de
films non parce qu'effectivement famille
recomposée familles différentes chacun
sa famille d'autant plus maintenant donc
c'est important les petits de tout de
suite leur expliquer que des choses
différentes sont possibles que même eux
ils peuvent être différentes ces voix là
c'est très important je trouve ça très
positif et ça va dans le sens de la
société et ceux qui sont choqués vous
leur répondez quoi parce que c'est là
c'est un vrai problème de société il ya
quand même des gens encore qu'ils font
là le sujet pour but affiché de
sensibles et difficile ils sont choqués
relativement aux modèles de la famille
qui existait au raisonnement
traditionnel mais aujourd'hui et depuis
de nombreuses années ça a changé donc il
fallait dans l'air du temps on est
obligé alors j'ai demandé à quelqu'un
qui est dans la tradition banni le mot
je vous êtes choqués ce qui me semble
avoir les chevilles et vous comprenez le
polémique ces deux questions un peu
différente moi je suis jeune vache je
comprends la polémique je suis choquée
parce que ce n'est pas du tout parce que
enfin qu'il y ait des familles
homoparentales qui me choque évidemment
c'est que ils ont trois ans ils n'ont
pas encore le logiciel pour pour leur
expliquer ce que ça peut être c'est trop
ça serait très bien pour des pour des
jeunes un peu plus voilà
émotionnelle après le modifier
iliad a voulu leur faire intégrer que
c'est la norme y en a je leur dis pas
gâcher 913 il ya une norme difficile à
savoir mais cac 40 a mis donc on n'a pas
le logis s'ils n'ont pas le logiciel
pour comprendre pour l'instant on le
laisse donc
sans problème
c'est que ça n'est pas pour vous et moi
ça ne fait pas de ce n'est pas normal ce
n'est pas la norme
bluetooth est d'accord
what the
suis comprend la polémique moi j'ai des
enfants en bas âge
les enfants ne sont pas équipés pour
comprendre ces sujets ils vont forcément
poser des questions et ses complexes de
leur expliquer et je trouve que c'est
pas adapté à des petits enfants je ne
suis absolument pas choqué par la
thématique je trouve que ses actuels
c'est dans l'air du temps il faut qu on
en parle ce sont des sujets de société
mais je pense qu'on projette trop des
sujets d'adultes sur des petits angles
en crever et c'est au monde non mais ce
sont des thématiques d'adultes non mais
j'ai pris l'habitude de jouer juste
finir il faudrait laisser un petit peu
d'insouciance et de voilà de légèreté à
la vider son côté coop allégé
journée juste un an j'entends ce que tu
dis mais on a l'impression que c'est
justement toi qui plaquent le sujet
comme si c'était une problématique
graves et importantes or là c'est
traiter de façon extrêmement légère
c'est un petit ourson il a une maman et
une maman si on le redit à
25 ooo
bureaux censés cp papilles un copain qui
ronge les sangs n'osais pas plus on en
dit pas moi c'est par exemple moi j'ai
des petits neveux des petites nièces ils
ont fait ce qu'ils sont vraiment des bb
bb qui vont à la crèche parce que leurs
parents travaillent et à la crèche yade
ya deux papas qui viennent déposer loeb
eh ben on leur dit what you buy il ya
une représentation voilà encore un bébé
n'a même pas conscience qu'ils regardent
ppp j'espère que tu étais ne montre pas
papy à un bébé qui est encore à la
crèche mais papy qui
ont fait si vous voulez dire plus rapide
dans le bain ça s'adresse à des enfants
qui parlent déjà acquis en quoi 3 5 ans
et donc ils savent que quand ils voient
un une femme enceinte il ya un bébé dans
le ventre d'une maman etc c'est toutes
ces problématiques et c'est toutes les
polémiques de la société qui sont
extrêmement inflammable extrêmement
polémique
pas du tout j'entends parler de normes
de logiciels c'est quand même chaud non
mais c'est quand même nom mais à vous
deux éditeurs de logiciels mais s'il ya
des problèmes aujourd'hui dans nos
sociétés sur ces débats c'est parce que
nous même on découvre sec enfants pour
nous on n'a pas été justement éduquer on
n'a pas appris à reconnaître tous ces
types de parentalité mais c'est une
émission une émission les capacités
messi et 329 épisode c'est une émission
qui a fait avancer la société est là
mais bon c'est grâce à ça que rappeler
problème en maternelle par exemple il
peut y avoir deux maman ou de papa qui
viennent déposer leurs enfants
s'initient le petit a vu les papilles et
ben pour lui ah bah tiens il ya comme
dans le dessin animé moi j'ai un papa
une maman lui la deux mamans où elle est
là deux papas et tout ça semble assez
simple bonne et on n'a pas besoin d'en
dire plus ce sont effectivement petit et
on développera et on parlera avec eux à
6 7 8 10 ans 15 ans